Brennan who got a forget some fights out
Saturday I'm stuck in my home so that's
gonna I don't that'll uh chop up the
boredom a little bit daddy you know the
lung hi I'm gonna be stuck in your in
your house that's right buddy but I'm
gonna break down the face and I want to
get your I want to see what you think of
my breakdown that's it you want to start
with the you want to start with the main
event you want to start with just gonn
Drive didn't i'm grande and start with
that
my favorite fight on the card will top
five is on the main event on the prelims
those Damir was that jerry that jury
guys he's from rides and he's the light
heavyweight champ over there he's a
monster
oh yeah I did not know I've seen full
can obviously fight a lot I've not seen
that other guy from Reisman he's a beast
yeah and and he they're both because I
think in here made me a striker right
yeah it's gonna be a its own getting
knocked down yeah I do you have anything
to say about any of the tree limb or
early pre-med you're good man they're
really good those Muslims good Bogota
for Santos is good it's so funny I was
looking at the best Russian wrestlers of
all time I watched these videos and
almost all of them all the legendary
wrestlers are all from so when you say
Russian wrestling they're almost all
Dagestan yes so far like the top guys
so there's conception tradition to that
and then leads organizer by John yes so
I'm excited about the and Ronde rose
namajunas fight because Rose was piecing
her up and and and you know when Jessica
picked her up to her on her head
obviously she can avoid that I mean
she's so goddamn strong but I don't
think there's any comparison in terms of
skill level striking etc probably eating
jiu-jitsu I think the only danger is
all due respect but the only danger is
for her to get picked up and thrown
around again I don't see her no I that's
not fair to do to just entourage talk
about a former champ she's not just good
at picking up and thrown girls on her
head she's not with you she has really
good striking well Rose is a big
favorite though yes she comes forward
though like when she the way she did
with the tank shame she just comes
straight forward and with that check
hook in that jab I don't know Matt it's
gonna be tough with to fight rose that
way it didn't work the first time and if
there's a change in plans
I don't know how it works the second
time so Rose should get it done
yeah though you skip one thought that
Paige Vanzant she's the biggest dog on
the card which is interesting because a
girl who she's fighting the Brazilian
Amanda yeah this is pages of really yeah
Reba's losses have been she got clipped
you know and can't crack a little bit
it's not terrible I mean - nine hundred
Jesus Christ can you explain what that
means betting wise I mean you gotta put
nine hundred dollars on Amanda to win a
hundred G's it's not yeah that's that's
that's it's not a bad bet to take Paige
well you want to be out of this world
page one that's funny right right that's
good and then what about let's see
what's the next fight let me see if he
wins it'd be the biggest win let me to
speak it'd be shocking and incredible
but Yanis such a [ __ ] beast hips is
boxing so ridiculously good he's younger
it's like his time yeah it's really
learned it did that yeah I don't have
that much momentum like
not definitely good but you know Josie
Otto I thought anymore the glass fight
against and people prize of that he's
done work man
I think you know Peter young hasn't had
like that huge signature lanius nowhere
near the experience it's not again it's
not if you're trying to make money it's
not bad to bet on the dogs jose aldo's a
dog you can see Joe's a winning easily
really yeah I love I love just now that
was not like if the weight cups not prom
for Joe's in he looks fine against
tomorrow it's a tough fight for Peter
Yan that's definitely a shoo-in for
Peter he's a monster
anything great be in Russian but it's
not a shoe it just seems that so much
goddamn power boom just catches you with
those it's kind of unforgiving so I
don't know doesn't have a ton of
finishes you finish your eyes one of
them is like a big knockout artist knows
that would be the knockdown
- how many finishes these guys have I
just think he's so young and he's so
he's he looks so [ __ ] sound
fundamentally sound he does everything
right so out of his UFC fights yes Regis
engines three finishes yeah yeah he's my
favorite for god sakes which is
impossible to do yeah
your eyes also forty I mean you know
yeah and and Josie has a lot of miles on
rooting for because I'd love to see him
win but I think if he does win it's a
it's a it's a big deal
it'd be it'd be a [ __ ] is huge
exciting win for it yes and no I mean
yes most people thought meet Marlon
that's why I gave him this fight he look
at the odds he's not that big of an
underdog either that's a close fight
that's a close fight I'm excited yeah
that's a good now the Beast but it's a
lot for me chew off minute yeah so you
think so Wow
I thought you definitely have gone
without question no I always go for the
underdogs bench switch we plan make
money I like the dogs in this card
look man now we got we got alexander
prokhanov ski and max Holloway great and
I don't their [ __ ] bull can ask you
with those goddamn leg kicks I don't
know what max is gonna do I here's what
I think if I miss camp I go like this I
say to max I go you have to knock him
out in the first [ __ ] around
max landed more headshots and body shots
he only lost with the lake leg kids so
if he addresses those leg kicks keeps
putting in some work and maybe not be so
stagnant maybe not take such a wide
stance
but then again you're assuming book nos
he's gonna come with the same game plan
which is right which he wouldn't do if
he came with the exact same game plan is
gonna lose like it you think max will
throw more leg kicks himself no I think
every times your throne is gonna make it
peg right so he's gonna step in and then
Jabbar punch him yeah Volken asti he get
his thing that element of surprise is
gone so you can't do the same game plan
otherwise you're definitely gonna lose
Canty max hasn't answered was like kids
I bet you've woken up he starts using
his wrestling really you tried taking
down five times in their first fight one
suggest ball five but who knows if he
was purposely trying to do it or if he
just trying to mix it up I think those
guys are all [ __ ] killers again I'm
see I'm again I think that I think that
he's so [ __ ] awesome
Max's you know it's that you can make
learning the best 45o of all time but
then again he's got a lot of mileage and
I I tend to go with the younger I don't
know if he didn't focus he's younger but
I think it has less mileage
no you I like yeah I
myself going with house key I get a dot
I mean Vegas is with you two men yes
yeah go to the main event son well a
couple things number one you got horses
must be though I'm going with Moscow who
you can take it on he's a big dog yeah
but I but here's the thing they say
those months a better wrestler that's
fine but remember you know Jorge months
but I'll speaks espanol
yeah and he's good French the guy I
don't know if you ever heard him called
Yoel Romero who is also a wrestler and
he's been he's been bringing in the best
wrestlers in the world apparently in
American Top Team he was Gus appraised
main sparring partner for the entire
time he's not been out of camp the only
question is it one that he was 194 I
think on Friday when he actually signed
the dotted line according to him that's
huge so he's got to lose or 192 he's got
to lose a little weight and travel and
their sleep issues that back then that
makes me wondering about cardio what's
gonna happen that's that's a big factor
but Mossman else is so [ __ ] good I
think he's a way better striker all due
respect and I don't think that he's
gonna be bothered by the restaurant so I
gotta go with Mazda using [ __ ] get the
done via TKO or something I do I do
I mean look man it's it's it's a tall
order I know whose mom is a monster and
awesome but I just prefer shits and
giggles and some fun I don't know I love
both guys I don't know how the fights
gonna play as well I feel like goostman
doesn't get the respect he deserves ever
ever the Woodley look what he did to
Kobe coming ten like you a monster man
we also his cardio is ridiculous he's so
fun big and strong he's just a there's a
reason he's a champion I know he got
that he got that [ __ ] belt and did it
decisively with all of them and by the
way his striking is is punishing but I
do think if he tries to stand and
banging with monster doll he's going to
lose that exchange and the advantage
that Guzman may have his cardio I don't
know what
wait cut the Travis didn't like yeah you
know you know yeah count on that yeah
we're we're good
I'm surprised at the oddsmakers man
Guzman's almost two-to-one favorite yeah
I don't know I think they're thinking
about wrestling I think they're thinking
about this size I think thinking about
it's cardio I think they're looking at
must because weight cut that's got to
it's a big weight cut you know the
travel you know but and also what's my
like you said us no joke but look it's
Mozgov it's just Mozgov dog I don't know
how you put your you're not putting your
gloves on his face not as much as he's
putting them on yours he's just I don't
know man
my thing burns yeah burns it's just a
fight we wanted you know if this fight
doesn't [ __ ] kick the cogut out of my
chest man this right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue
okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]